The rescue of the Wild Boar football team...
...has been a herculean international effort.
The team leading the boys out was comprised of 12 divers...
...led by four elite Thai navy seals.
It's thought that divers alongside them were from Britain,...
...the US, Japan and Australia, including the ex-Aussie SAS diving doctor.
Around a hundred divers have been involved in the operation,...
...including volunteers from China, Laos, Myanmar, Denmark...
...and Finland to help lay guide ropes and pre-position supplies...
...and oxygen tanks along the route.
The Wild Boars, who had embarked on an adventure...
...that nearly went so very badly wrong, seem in reasonable shape.
Tonight, their parents are seeing them at the hospital...
...albeit through glass in their isolation unit.